je suis heureux de venir ce matin de
bravoure pour avoir la possibilité de
m'exprimer
et d'expliquer un certain nombre de
choses de clarifier effectivement des
incompréhensions qui ici ou là ont pu
être véhiculé si vous permettez je
souhaiterais d'abord rendre hommage aux
trente mille hommes et femmes de la
réserve de la réserve de la gendarmerie
nationale parce que ce sont des
personnes de tout statut de tous âges
qui prennent sur leur temps libre pour
venir renforcer les unités venir
renforcer la gendarmerie et contribuer
par là à la sécurité de nos concitoyens
sur les territoires ils sont extrêmement
méritant ils sont actuellement engagés
de manière très forte à la fois sur la
sécurité des zones estivale mais aussi
sur le tour de france
ils ont été engagées de manière
exceptionnelle à l'occasion des
événements d'hier irma sur saint martin
et en 2017 80 d'entre eux ont été
blessés en service dont 20 à la suite
d'une agression
donc je souhaitais vraiment leur rendre
hommage parce que aujourd'hui sans nos
réservistes
nous ne pourrions pas fonctionner de
manière optimale comme nous le
fonctionnent je les en remercie
et j'en témoigne à travers cette
occasion toute ma reconnaissance
j'aurai ensuite articles et mon propos
en deux points le premier conserve la
réserve militaire et son organisation
l'arrière militaires des gens brik a
deux composantes global d'une réserve
opérationnelle et une réserve citoyenne
la réserve opérationnelle elle renforce
au quotidien l'action de la gendarmerie
les militaires de réserve sont les
missions qui sont celles de leurs des
personnes natives à l'exclusion du
maintien de l'ordre
et elle se compose de 29 1847 volontaire
titulaire d'un contrat spécial dans la
réserve
à la date d'aujourd'hui en moyenne tous
les jours depuis le début d'année
1670 réservistes chaque jour renforcent
nos unités territoriales le rize habite
opérationnel dit de sécurité publique
donc celui que vous rencontrez dans la
rue
il est donc soumis aux mêmes droits et
les mêmes devoirs que les militaires
d'actifs il il est placé dans l'ordre
hiérarchique au même niveau que les
personnels d'activ il est soumis au même
statut et détenteur d'un grade qui est
soumis aux règles d'avancement classique
pour ce qui concerne donc cette réserve
opérationnelle de sécurité publique
il existe aussi la réserve
opérationnelle une catégorie
particulière de réservistes
correspondant à des spécialistes
c'est l'article l42 21-3 du code de la
défense qui prévoit cette catégorie ces
volontaires sont recrutés pour exercer
des fonctions particulières déterminé
correspondant soit et des qualifications
soit et des expériences et qui sont
capables d'apporter des choses se sont
donc de personnel ressources pour le
service dans le cadre notamment de
réflexion qui sont lancés dans
différents domaines
le grade qu'il aurait conféré est
conféré à titre temporaire
il ne permet pas d'avoir des compétences
en matière d'encadrement et il est
accordée uniquement pour la durée de la
mission et dans le cadre de la mission
il n'y a donc aucune prérogative de
commandement pour ses réserves et
spécialistes quel que soit le grade
qu'on leur attribue depuis 2002 l'agent
armée nationale a recruté 124
réservistes spécialistes et à ce jour
nous en avons 64 ans la grande réserve
opérationnelle c'est donc le premier
point avec des réservistes de sécurité
publique et des réservistes spécialistes
la réserve citoyenne elle et les fortes
2315 réservistes citoyens
elle vise en fait à entretenir l'esprit
défense à entretenir le lien entre la
nation et forces armés entre la
gendarmerie et la population et
les grades qui sont conférés dans le cas
de cette réserve sperian sur dégrade
également honorifique qui n'emporte
aucune prérogative de commandement et
qui évidemment n'ont pas vocation à
assurer des missions de sécurité
publique
ces trésors citoyenne est une réserve
qui est tout à fait transparente
puisqu'elle fait l'objet de décisions
formelles les personnels de la réserve
citoyenne porte d'ailleurs régulièrement
à l'occasion des cérémonies d un signe
distinctif qui permettent de savoir
qu'ils ou elles font partie de cette
réserve citoyenne
voilà un petit peu la réserve militaire
d'avions abritel que je souhaitais vous
la présenter de manière globale
s'agissant des deux personnes objet de
du travail de votre commission messieurs
alexandre bédat la l1 sans kraz je
souhaiterais simplement apporter là
aussi quelques précisions sur le
processus qui a conduit à leur
recrutement et à leur emploi alexandre
benalla étaient engagés dans la réserve
opérationnelle depuis 2009 dans le cadre
d'un travail de sécurité publique
générale dans le département de l'eure
tout à fait naturellement il a fait 184
jours au total entre 2009 et 2015 et
depuis 2015 il n'a plus jamais été
employée par ce que il n'est pas le
temps voilà donc il ya pas de raison
particulière mais en tout cas il a été
employé de manière importante 194 jours
de 2009 à 2015 c'est un des périodes
intéressantes au cours de laquelle il a
donné satisfaction et tous les éléments
qui me sont remontés ne faisait état
d'aucune difficulté jeudi
et ni de comportement dit d'engagement
j'ai rencontré monsieur benalla à
l'occasion différents déplacements
notamment à l'occasion du retour de
saint martin où nous avons eu l'occasion
de discuter dans l'avion manière de
choses et d'autres et également de son
engagement dans la réserve et de sa
vision de la protection de la sécurité
des personnes il faut savoir que en
dernier trimestre 2002 2e se laisse
cependant 2017
nous avons eu un certain nombre
d'agressions de jean dardé d'incendié de
caserne on a eu un incendie à grenoble
de l'ensemble des garages avec 50
véhicules qui ont brûlé
on a eu l'incendié incendié à limoges de
véhicules également on a eu un incendie
de casernes abellan qui visait les
familles et on a tous les ans un certain
nombre d'agressions contre les gendarmes
on a plu l'an dernier peu à peu près
1926 gendarmes qui ont fait l'objet
d'agressions dans le cadre de leur
service quotidien
il me paraissait intéressant pour sortir
un peu de notre réflexion globale
puisqu'on avait lancé un groupe de
travail de réflexion sur cette fonction
protection du personnel me paraissait
intéressant d'avoir un oeil extérieur
je considérais que compte tenu de son
expérience en matière de protection des
personnalités
il aurait il était un personnel
ressources utiles que j'ai donc intégré
dans le vivier de ses réserves et
spécialistes le deuxième personnage
monsieur vincent kraz lui à une
situation un peu différente puisque il a
été intégré dans la réserve
opérationnelle en 1996 en provenance de
l'armée de l'air il a progressé dans le
cadre de la réserve opérationnelle de
sécurité publique
classiquement nommé capitaine puis chef
d'escadron grade qu'il détient encore
aujourd'hui il a régulièrement effectuer
des missions de formation d'encadrement
et totalise à ce jour 4 114 jours deux
convocations à l'horizon il a été versé
dans cette réserve et il y assure de
manière là aussi satisfaisante en tout
cas de ski mais remonter ses fonctions à
la fois de formateurs d'encadrants c'est
d'ailleurs dans ces fonctions
d'encadrants qu'il était employé au sein
du commandement militaire de l'île voilà
un petit peu les grandes idées sur les
deux personnels concernés dont je
précise
pour l'ensemble de l'information et la
totale informations d'autres commissions
qu' aucun d'entre eux n'était activé
comme réserviste le 1er mai nous avons
effectivement 30000 réservistes ces
réservistes ils ont une vie puisque
normalement ils font partie de la
société civile
et ils ne sont considérés comme
réserviste que lorsque il faut l'objet
d'une convocation formelle tracé qu'on
retrouve dans nos outils de gestion et à
ce moment là effectivement quand ils
sont convoqués et engagés ils doivent
répondre à la discipline militaire et
ils s'en souviendront le reste du temps
je dirais qu'ils ont leur vie
personnelle et le commandement n'a pas à
s'immiscer dans leur vie personnelle
voilà un petit peu les différents
éléments le président que je souhaitais
apporter en propos liminaire pour la
bonne information de votre commission
merci ce directeur de deux de ses propos
relatifs à la réserve de forme de
réserve
je vais bien sûr maintenant laisser la
parole à god deux rapporteurs et comme
je voulais dire après aux membres de la
commission qui pour vous poser les
questions qu'ils souhaiteront bien sûr
celle ci dépassera peut-être les
questions relatifs à la réserve et
aurez-vous sans doute des questions sur
pour vérifier les propos qui nous ont
été donnés hier où par le passé ou que
nous avons entendu en retraçant les
éléments de l'enquète de l'assemblée
nationale concernant le type de relation
que pouvait avoir en particulier
monsieur bénalia avec
la gendarme alors je vais donner tout
d'abord la parole à notre apport heures
muriel jourda
merci monsieur d'abord vous indiquez
vous préciser vous assurer de toute la
considération nous pouvons avoir ici je
pense unanimement dans cette commission
pour les forces de gendarmerie et la
gratitude aussi nous avons pour votre
action je laisserais sans doute à
d'autres le soin de reparler de la
réserve
j'aurais pour ma part quelques questions
sur la présence de monsieur benalla dans
les réunions relatives à la sécurité
publique et dans les cercles du
ministère de l'intérieur puisque jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
tous les témoignages que nous avons pu
avoir nous ont révélé son omniprésence
au sein de ces instances alors j'ai
trois questions sur ce point 3 série
d'interrogations
d'abord vous êtes vous en mesure de
confirmer ces affirmations c'est-à-dire
l'omniprésence de monsieur benalla dans
les réunions relatives à la sécurité
publique dans les cercles du ministère
de l'intérieur
quel était selon vous les missions
exactes qui étaient exercées par
monsieur benalla avez vous eu
connaissance de la participation de
celui ci en qualité d'observateur à
d'autres opérations de maintien de
l'ordre et le cas échéant où et quand et
enfin avez vous été informé par vos
propres services de la présence de
monsieur benalla à des réunions autour
de hauts responsables de la police et de
la gendarmerie nationale merci madame le
rapporteur pour c'est pour ces questions
merci pour votre soutien la gendarmerie
alors la présence de monsieur benalla
aux différentes réunions auxquelles moi
j'ai pu participer
je n'ai pas vu au rayon mr l'intérieur
très clairement
donc moi je n'ai pas constaté même pas
une omniprésence en fait je n'ai pas
constaté sa présence tout simplement
s'agissant des missions exactes de
monsieur bella là je serais bien
incapable de vous les donner
j'ai entendu comme vous ce qu'a dit le
directeur de cabinet j'ai constaté
effectivement qu'à l'occasion de
cérémonies majeurs notamment je pense à
l'hommage alors nobel tram ou le 14
juillet je le voyais effectivement je
dirais dans le comme on dit dans le
paysage maintenant moi je suis bien
incapable de vous dire qu'elles étaient
ses fonctions exactes d'ailleurs ça
échappe totalement à mon domaine de
compétence
est-ce qu'il a participé à d'autres
opérations de maintien nord j'avoue que
là aussi j'en ai vraiment aucune idée et
ce n'est pas non plus dans mon domaine
de compétence pour le coup moi j'avais
des relations je dirais avec lui dans le
cadre des réflexions qu'on aurait pu
mener d'ailleurs il se trouve que aurait
été même en tant que réserviste
spécialistes je ne vais jamais convoqué
on n'a jamais eu le temps en fait il est
toujours très très près ce que je peux
comprendre mais voilà donc moi j'ai pas
de connaissance d' opérations auxquelles
ils auraient participé
voilà merci mon général je vous salue
avec un peu de retard je voyais là en
excuser dans les opérations de sécurité
autour du président de la république à
l'occasion de ses déplacements
monsieur beynat la donne est il des
ordres aux fonctionnaires de gendarmerie
[Musique]
le président là dessus alors évidemment
je suis je ne suis pas la totalité des
pass prend du plaisir en toute hypothèse
est en tout cas pour ce que je suis
tellement je parle parler de saint
martin tout à l'heure j'avais donné
aucun ordre aux gendarmes
celui qui est l'autorité légitime pour
le gendarme c'est le préfet c'est le
préfet qui est responsable au niveau du
département et sept au préfet qu'on
rencontre et c'est le préfet qui donne
des directives très clairement mais ce
benalla n'avait pas ni la légitimité ni
d'ailleurs la compétence pour imposer
demander où vous solliciter quelques
modifications aux quelques dispositions
que ce soit dans les dents les voyages
de officiel auquel il participait merci
madame jourdain
nassim président de me redonner la
parole je le reste de la question vous a
peut être échappé général allez vous été
informé par vos services de la présence
de monsieur médias autour des réunions
car vous n'avez pas constater vous même
vos services dont il a formé non
dans les différents comptes rendus de
réunions auxquelles mais les
collaborateurs peuvent participer donc
régulièrement ils me font des comptes
rendus de réunions
on pourra d'ailleurs le documenter si
vous le souhaitez il n'y avait pas enfin
en tout cas moi j'ai pas vu la présence
monsieur benalla ni d'ailleurs
personnellement ni à travers les comptes
rendus comme on a fait je remercie alors
de ses réponses à nu une question
j'avais dit que je ne parlerai pas de la
réserve mais tout de même vous nous avez
indiqué que vous l'avez intégré dans la
réserve opérationnelle en tant que
spécialistes au regard des missions
qu'il a exercé vous me dites est
incapable de dire quels sont ses
missions que vous l'avez jamais vu
travailler autrement que très
partiellement
comment avez vous pu alors apprécier ses
missions et estimé qu'il devait être
intégré à ce grade alors même que vous
me dit n'en avoir aucune connaissance
personnelle je suis mal exprimé la
question me semblait correspondre aux
fonctions qu'il a actuellement au sein
de la présidence
bon là il ment c'est pas dans vos
domaines de compétences en revanche
préalablement à son intégration
on était sûr quelqu'un qui manifestement
avait assuré la sécurité des autres
personnalités de toute nature de tous
bords de est donc dans ce cadre là il me
paraissait d'avoir une expérience
intéressante il avait suivi les études
de master en matière de sécurité
publique suivi une session 10h et des
aides régionales même si voilà et il me
semblait en tout cas quelqu'un qui
pouvait apporter des choses c'était ça
l'idée en fait c'est finalement c'est
impersonnel ressources parfois quand on
mène des réflexions
on nous reproche à juste titre d'être
tous vents autocentré voilà bon et alors
réfléchissez entre vous instituez c'est
vrai et l'idée justement c'est à la
faveur de des ressources que nous avons
chez nos réservistes et certains
d'ailleurs nous disent il faut nous nous
solliciter davantage
ils ont raison et donc les réservistes
débat là on a des choses à vous apporter
on a des visions différentes qui sont
qui sont intéressantes pour vous et
c'est donc dans ce cadre là que ce
benalla pour moi constituer un personnel
ressources dans un vivier il se trouve
que pour des raisons dirait d'emploi du
temps il n'a pas été activée donc voilà
la réponse que je vous ai donné ses
fonctions actuelles le vian je n'ai pas
mis à en connaître je connais pas le
détail en revanche pour avoir discuté
avec lui bien entendu j'ai constaté
malgré son jeune âge qu'il avait une
expérience il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que l'âge qu'il a aussi ici
ou là fait l'objet de discussions on a
quand même dans notre société actuelle
des jeunes et très jeunes qui fait
partie des anciens je peux le dire
qui monte des entreprises réussi ce qui
finalement portent haut les couleurs de
la france qui l'a je ne fais rien à
faire alors après on me dit oui vous
auriez dû peut-être peut-être
j'ai peut-être là aussi était peut-être
trop peu enthousiaste par rapport une
vision un peu extérieur qui me
paraissait intéressante dans le cadre de
cette protection des personnels
protection des personnels et des
infrastructures qui pour moi est une
priorité du commandement est la mienne
mon devoir à moi c'est de protéger mes
personnels et pour protéger mes
personnels il faut que j'ai des avis à
360 de gens qui ont des choses à dire
des choses à apporter et qui peuvent
nous interpeller dans nos certitudes
parce que nos meilleurs ennemis c'est
nos certitudes en général est ce que
madame jourdain a terminé non mais je
sais les autres s'exprimer quand je vous
nommez un tel grade dans la réserve
un gendarme réserviste
est ce qu'il y à une sorte de procédure
de jury est ce que votre avis personnel
se fonde sur un rapport est ce que on
procède à une audition
comment ça se passe alors il ya le
président il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de jury a pas de commission en fait il
ya un travail de détection
alors ça se fait pas forcément
d'ailleurs par le directeur général
moi j'ai à peu près aujourd'hui une
centaine de réservistes qui sont
rattachés au cabinet voyez donc sur tous
les autres réservistes on a des contacts
qui se font au niveau régional au niveau
du département
donc c'est souvent des contacts intuiti
personae qui conduisent à échanger à des
personnes importantes dans tel ou tel
domaine qui peut nous apporter des
choses dans le domaine de la cyber dans
le domaine de de la biologie enfin il ya
pis y'a plein de domaines dans lequel on
peut avoir des besoins
ensuite il ya une proposition qui est
faite et qui est travaillé par le
commandement des réserves
donc effectivement un dossier qui est
monté
sur l'opportunité ou non d'intégrer
telle ou telle personne dans la réserve
ce dossier il me parvient avec la vie
tout le monde et c'est effectivement moi
qui pars délégation pouvoir du ministre
intègre les gens dans la réserve et donc
c'est une décision que je prends mais
après les avis je dirais successifs mais
y'a pas il n'y a pas de formalisation de
commissions il n'y a pas d'avis
collégiale ya effectivement un processus
d'études juridiques des choses qui se
sont fait se sont faites de manière
réglementaire en s'appuyant sur des
textes dont il n'y a pas eu de n'a pas
contourné les textes on les a appliqués
voilà je sais pas si j'ai répondu à
votre question que oui je vous remercie
mon général mais dans ce cas nous allons
vous demander la communication
bien sûr ce dossier je voudrais
maintenant donner la parole à notre
rapporteur
monsieur jean pierre sueur merci
monsieur le président en général
monsieur le directeur je voulais d'abord
m'associer aux propos de muriel jourda
par rapport à la l'estiment qui est la
nôtre pour la gendarmerie vous savez que
nous sommes des élus de territoire et
nous connaissons bien nos communes et
nous avons beaucoup de contacts avec la
gendarmerie dont nous apprécions
particulièrement le travail et c'est ce
qui me permet de revenir sur la question
posée à la fois par muriel jourda par
philippe bas voyez vous nous avons même
quelquefois des contacts informels avec
des gendarmes
et je peux vous dire que ayant eu
l'occasion récemment d'avoir de tels
contacts
je ne peux vous cacher que il y a quand
même quelques interrogations comme vous
avez dit sur l'ascension rapide de
monsieur bénalia au grade vous avez cité
georges brassens qui dit que le temps ne
fait rien dallas faire vous eussiez pu
citer aussi pierre corneille ma chère
collègue
dit que la valeur n'attend point le
nombre des années
mais toutefois je connais et on connaît
des jeunes extrêmement brillant
compétents dans la réserve qui ne
bénéficie aucunement de cet avancement
extrêmement accéléré c'est à dire que ça
nous nous ne pouvons pas ne pas nous
poser de questions devant le fait que
lui justement lui bénéficie de ce haut
grade on a parlé vous avez cité votre
camarade malheureusement tombé dans les
conditions héroïque que vous connaissez
des gens m'ont dit mais enfin non
colonel c'est pas rien
lieutenant-colonel dans la gendarmerie
même dans la réserve donc est ce que
vraiment est ce que ça vaut suisse est
passée vous paraît naturel normal
habituels ou est-ce que ça vous paraît
atypique j'aurai une autre question si
le président le permet en général
à vous de répondre merci monsieur
rapporteur pour cette question qui me
donne l'occasion effectivement de
préciser encore davantage mes propos
liminaire j'ai entendu les
interrogations en interne puisque depuis
la fin de semaine dernière j'ai beaucoup
de remonter à la fois de réservistes et
de personnes d'actifs qui pour certains
d'ailleurs manifeste une colère très
clair je j'ai fait oeuvre de pédagogie
d'abord vers mes personnels par écrit en
leur donnant quelques éléments
techniques ce que je devais tout à
l'heure dans les propos liminaires
j'ai fait une visioconférence lundi
matin qu on fait régulièrement avec les
commandants de région est gérée à cette
occasion l'a expliqué à nouveau un
certain nombre de un certain nombre de
choses dans ce que j'ai expliqué c'est
pour ça que je voudrais revenir c'est
qu' il n'y a pas eu d'avancement c'est
pas une ascension en matière de carrière
ces deux statuts différents
monsieur benalla faisait partie de la
réserve opérationnelle de sécurité
publique avec un grab qu'il conserve si
demain il revient dans cette réserve
il reprendra son grade initiale de
réserve opérations ainsi que des prix
le grade dans la réserve spécialistes
est ingrate temporaire qui n'emporte
aucune prérogative de puissance publique
bien entendu il n'y de commandement donc
on n'est pas sur une logique
d'avancement on est sur une logique de
deux statues qui sont complètement
différents alors après évidemment quand
on regarde la cinétique on y va
finalement il est passé de tels ghardaïa
g sauf que c'est pas les mêmes statuts
voilà un petit peu donc est ce que ça
peut susciter de l'interrogation et la
colère je le comprends je m'en suis
expliqué avec les mets mes troupes je
continuerai on expliqué
mais surtout ce que je souhaiterais dire
c'est que c'est une décision que j'ai
prise en mon âme et conscience par
rapport au niveau auquel je souhaitais
employés monsieur benalla et je reviens
là dessus c'est à dire finalement ils
devaient partir devait faire partie
d'une personne ressource dans le cadre
d'un groupe de réflexion sur la
protection des personnels et des
infrastructures dans le cadre de ce
travail il devait travailler avec des
généraux et des officiers supérieurs de
tous de touran notamment les colonels
bon pardon est un peu triviale mais dans
le monde militaire
quand on discute avec des gens souvent
le premier réflexe est de regarder le
code-barres regarde le code-barres le
regarde ce qu'il ya sur les épaulettes
alors on peut le regretter mais moi je
vous dis la vérité c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné quand on a en face de soi
ou quand les gens auront en face d'eux
un officier subalterne attitude bon
allez 10 il est bien gentil lui mais bon
nous on a aimé qu'l sérieux on est en
haut de la pyramide ensuite je dis ça
comme ça parce que c'est la réalité et
donc il me paraissait important pour que
cette réflexion se fâche je dirais de
manière partagée de manière intelligente
que je le positionne à un niveau où les
gens l'écoutent
mais encore une fois ce grade n'emporte
aucune conséquence ou autorité
quelconque sur quelques personnels de la
jambe riz que ce soit alors tant que
c'est fin j'étais un peu long pardon
merci au contraire de monsieur sur la
collègue muriel jourda bleus soufflent
cette cette question de comment alors je
vais la garder pour moi si tu considères
qui d'abord je veux poser une question
très précise sur les événements qui se
sont déroulés à roissy à l'occasion du
retour tu l'équipe de france de football
dont la sécurité était assurée par la
gendarmerie nationale et il nous a été
déclaré que monsieur benalla des temps
présents il y avait eu quelques comment
vais-je dire discussion où quelques
problèmes
eux et je voulais savoir ce qui s'est
passé exactement
est-ce que les relations entre les
responsables de la gendarmerie et
monsieur ban à laon était d'une totale
sérénité et d'une complémentarité tout à
fait clair et plus largement est sûr
j'en termine ainsi monsieur le président
ne pensez vous pas qu on est dans un
système et c'est peut-être le fond de
cette commission d' enquête qui n'est
pas satisfaisant parce qu'il y a
constamment interférences nous nous
considérons tout simplement il à la
gendarmerie avec ses structures et son
commandement c'est logique et ça marche
comme ça et ça marche correctement comme
ça qu'il y a le groupe de sécurité du
président de la république avec des
gendarmes et des policiers et qu'il ya
une autorité qui le dirige en lien avec
la direction de la police nationale et
de la gendarmerie nationale et le
ministre de l'intérieur voilà et que si
des personnes qui ne font pas partie de
la police et de la gendarmerie
interviennent tout le temps avec
éventuellement des accords altercation
et injonctions de ces personnes à
l'égard des militaires de la gendarmerie
ou des fonctionnaires de la police
il ya problème donc premièrement voici
deuxièmement quel jugement portez vous
sur les relations entre monsieur benalla
et les gendarmes et le commandement de
la gendarmerie dans les différents
évènements que vous avez connu et sur le
fond que pensez vous de la situation
ainsi créée
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire peut-être
pour qu'elle ne se reproduise allez-y
mon général merci le rapporteur pour
cette question alors l'incident
enfin l'événement plutôt que vous
évoquez à roissy
a été porté à ma connaissance par un
appel téléphonique d'un journaliste qui
me dit est ce que vous êtes au courant
le moment où ils m'appellent je n'étais
pas au courant
déjà c'est un premier signe de la nature
mineurs dudit incident parce que bon on
est dans une structure assez
hiérarchiser un peu pyramidale est
évidemment s'il y avait eu un clash
majeur je pense que j'aurais été avisés
tout de suite ce n'était pas le cas donc
je dis aujourd'hui beaucoup de moi je
suis pas au courant
pas de commentaire évidemment je me suis
quand même renseigné auprès de mes
troupes
j'ai eu le commandement de la jambe et
de transport aérien puisque c'est les
transports aériens qui était géré mais
des transports est un qui était
responsable de la partie en zone
réservée donc autour de l'avion qui va
dire oui il ya eu effectivement une
discussion une personne est venue se
présenter pour donner aux tentes et de
peut-être de donner des directives
le commandant de compagnie l'a poliment
renvoyé vers l'autorité légitime qui
étaient là en l'espèce le préfet chargé
de sécurité responsables sur les
aéroports
y a pas eu à ma connaissance d'après les
comptes rendus qui m'ont été faits
d'incidents d'altercations ou ou des
changes
des changes un peu vif il ya eu
finalement une personne qui s'est
adressé aux gendarmes genre il ya dix
mois je reçois mes ordres du préfet vous
allez voir le préfet et puis de ce que
j'en sais c'est banal est ensuite allé
voir le préfet ce qu'il en est arrivé
après je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
les choses se sont déroulées et donc
pour eux prolongé ma réponse je n'ai pas
eu connaissance dans les différents
déplacements d'incidents qui aurait pu
impliquer de ce benalla qui aurait voulu
imposer ceci ou cela je pense que ça me
ferait remonter et à chaque déplacement
officiel il ya bien entendu des réunions
qui se font sous l'autorité du préfet le
commandant groupement local si les
concernés dans sa zone de compétence il
établit une note de service
d'organisation du déplacement dans
lesquels responsabilités sont clairement
établies et dans ses responsabilités il
n'y a que des gendarmes
le camp regroupement il agit sous
l'autorité du préfet et ensuite et donne
des ordres aux gendarmes et le gendarme
lui il applique les ordres de ses chefs
et moi je n'ai pas connaissance des
mictions quelconque dans ce domaine là
de qui que ce soit merci mon général
c'est le rapporteur et je vais dans un
instant donné la parole aux collègues
qui l'ont demandée sur le régime de la
question en une minute
je les remercie d'avancé du respecté
mais mon général moi je veux d'abord
vous poser une question plus
institutionnel et d'organisation le
commandant militaire du palais de
l'elysée est un officier supérieur de la
garde républicaine si je ne m'abuse
actuellement le patron du groupement de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république est également un officier
supérieur de gendarmerie
cela intéresse la commission des lois de
savoir quels sont les liens
d'organisation de fonctionnement entre
la gendarmerie nationale le commandement
militaire du palais d'une part et ce
groupement d'autres pas merci monsieur
le président pour cette question qui me
donne aussi l'occasion de clarifier les
relations que nous avons avec un certain
nombre de structures de la gendarmerie
qui sont mises à disposition d'autres
institutions on a de bons exemples et
les on allait jean-louis spécialisés on
a un certain nombre de structures dans
lesquelles nous avons des gendarmes mais
qui sont mis à disposition d'autres
autorités
c'est exactement ce qui se passe à
l'elysée mon travail à moi c'est
finalement de mettre à disposition à peu
près 300 personnels gembrie toutes
catégories confondues entre le gs père
est accompagné de sécurité la présidente
d'art public qui dépend du premier
régiment de la garde républicaine mettre
à disposition ses personnels mais
ensuite très clairement je n'ai pas à
connaître du reste je n'ai pas à
m'immiscer ou à m'ingérer dans quelques
fonctionnement que ce soit
dans le domaine qui est le leur c'est
finalement leur métier c'est ce qui se
passe exactement pour les autres je
voulais évoquer la jambe et les gens me
spécialise gembrie de l'air la jambe
maritime
oui d'armement en fait j'ai des
personnels qui sont marqués gendarmes
qui sont formés gendarmes que je mets à
disposition que je sélectionne bien
entendu et ensuite une fois qu'ils sont
mis à disposition de l'autorité
fonctionnelle
il échappe pour ce qui concerne leur
fonctionnement et leur travail quotidien
à ma responsabilité je reste responsable
bien entendu s'il ya eu une faute
majeure s'il ya des blessés bien entendu
là on va les accompagner mais on est
bien dans une logique je dirais de
subsidiarité total et moi je n'ai pas à
connaître ni de ce que fait le j'espère
pour le coup encore moi ni de ce que
fait le commandant militaire de la ligue
en général plus complète de vraies
questions quand il s'agit d'évaluer de
promouvoir des personnels de gendarmerie
qui servent à l'elysée avez vous un rôle
oui bien sûr alors pas alors après ça
dépend de niveau hiérarchique auquel on
se situe le patron de la garde
républicaine
je dirais il a une commission
d'avancement et les sous-officiers sont
gérées par la garde républicaine et une
commission d'avancement qui se réunit et
bien entendu il prend la tâche du
commandant militaire pour de procéder ou
pas à l'avancement s'agissant des
officiers ils sont notés au premier
degré par le commandant militaire est
ensuite au deuxième degré par le patron
de la garde républicaine
s'agissant du commandant militaire
lui-même ou du patron du gspr comme ça
se fait dans d'autres structures
je demande une appréciation à l'autorité
d'emploi
l'autorité d'emploi m'envoie une
appréciation le directeur de cabinet du
président cement voit une appréciation
il envoie là-bas il remplit bien son
métier enfin il fait bien sa fonction
bras pour moi c'est quelqu'un de bien de
pas bien situé et à partir de ces
appréciations
je suis amené à intégrer ça dans son
dossier à faire sa notation juridique
définitive et ensuite à le présenter à
la commission d'avancement s'il ya lieu
y at il d'autres agents que des
fonctionnaires civils et militaires
c'est à dire de gendarmerie au sein du
gspr alors à ma connaissance il ya donc
des gendarmes ça c'est certain
il ya des policiers après je ne saurais
vous dire quel est le détail des
personnels qui sont employés dans la
chape pas encore une fois mon domaine de
compétence
merci mon général alors mes chers
collègues c'est monsieur françois
grosdidier qui a demandé la parole en
premier
merci monsieur vous avez une minute
non mais je n'aurais pas nécessairement
besoin on verra les jets revenir sur les
questions que vous a posé le président
bas même si
vous n'avez pas directement la
responsabilité du fonctionnement du gspr
on nous a décrit deûle pour les
syndicats de policiers des relations
exécrables entre monsieur benalla et les
membres du j'espère donc c'est venu aux
oreilles des syndicats de police
est-ce que c'est venu aussi aux oreilles
de la hiérarchie de la gendarmerie
par ailleurs est ce que vous avez eu à
connaître précisément du statut de
monsieur benalla parce que il est
présenté généralement comme chef de
cabinet adjoint
le ministre d'intérieur nous a dit qu'il
s'était autoproclamé chef de cabinet
adjoint lorsque vous le voyez vous
nécessairement 20 dossiers le concernant
puisque était réserviste il apparaît
sous quel statut et est ce que la
responsabilité de la sécurité de
l'elysée était réellement dans ses
versions non et je termine qu'elle sur
le gspr ont il y avait des idées
d'évolution
est-ce qu'il fonctionne bien comme il
est à parité police gendarmerie
ou est ce qu'il ya des évolutions
souhaitables à la route mutualisation et
que général a compris votre question mon
général merci chers collègues merci à
temps pour cette ces questions alors les
relations au sein du gspr jabou être
totalement ignorants de difficultés
qui dans vous fait l'écho moi j'ai pas
eu de remontée sur les relations entre
les uns et les autres d'abord je mets un
point d'honneur
alors ça peut vous paraître là aussi
peut-être étonnant mais en tout cas au
même titre que on a une longue habitude
des gendarmes spécialisés ou dès janvier
à disposition on a ici un commandement
militaire moi je reste dans mon couloir
il ya des choses que je dois savoir ça
concerne effectivement des personnels
sont blessés s'ils ont des problèmes
particuliers utilisent ça c'est mon job
c'est mon travail de les accompagner en
revanche tout ce qui concerne leur
métier ce qui concerne leur engagement
fonctionner le quotidien ce jeu n'est
pas en connaître
donc j'ai pas eu de remontée dans ce
domaine là en matière de relation et
donc je je répond directement à la
troisième question toutes les idées
d'évolution dont j'ai entendu parler
effectivement qui ont été évoqués
d'ailleurs depuis deux trois jours
je n'ai pas à en connaître en tant que
tel gérant connaître s'il ya des
conséquences en matière de mise à
disposition de personnel ou de
transferts budgétaires potentiel oui là
sont là c'est le responsable de
programme qui sera chargé de mettre en
place les effectifs de mettre en place
un tel ou tel budget mais
moi je n'ai pas vocation à contribuer et
participer à toute réflexion que ce soit
en matière de dévolution du j'espère à
ma connaissance le statut de monsieur
benalla pour moi je ne sais pas
exactement quel était son secret j'ai
entendu hier comme vous
qui était chargé de mission pour moi
d'ailleurs
n'ayant pas à interagir avec lui au plan
opérationnel et je n'avais pas vocation
à savoir exactement ce qu'il faisait
dans le dossier je ne crois pas qu'on
ait des références sur sa fonction en
tant que tel puisque ce n'était pas aux
titres sa fonction qu'il a été recruté
c'est bien au titre de son expérience en
matière de sécurité des personnes en
matière de sécurité des biens qu'ils
étaient recrutés il n'est pas ta pas
recruté au titre de sa fonction
merci mon général madame lherbier
monsieur le président en général quand
vous avez présenté ce banal à vous nous
avez dit justement l'avoir connu quand
il était chargé de la protection des
hautes personnalités
en gros c'est ce qui intéressait la
gendarmerie ce qui me pose comme que ce
que je me pose comme question c'est nous
sommes en inde et dans une période de
risque terroriste
les violences urbaines sont de plus en
plus lourdes
les civils qui gravitent autour du
président n'ont ils pas besoin d'avoir
un diplôme spécifique une formation
spécifique avec une sélection rigide
les officiers de gendarmerie de toute
évidence le concours est extrêmement
difficile
les concours de commissaire de police le
concours est extrêmement difficile
alors on trouve quand même bizarre que
des personnes sans référence spécifique
gras soit habilité à
ce chargé de la protection du président
la république mais même des hautes
personnalités
je pense que le diplôme attestent de
déontologie d'un calme et d'une dune
merci chaud soleil mon général à votre
avis général sur la le dispositif qui
est en place a les idées moi je suis
bien incompétent pour dire qui doit y
être qui doit pas y être
moi j'ai considéré avant de l'intégrer
dans la réserve spécialistes que au
regard de son expérience passée donc
bien avant 2017
ils avaient des connaissances
opérationnelles concrètes qui
m'intéressait une vision de la sécurité
une vision dynamique avec des autorités
qu'il a pour lesquelles il a participé à
la protection et je considérais que
c'était intéressant pour moi de le
prendre comme personnel ressources que
j'ai oublié de dire tout à l'heure je me
permet de profiter de cette question
pour apporter cette précision
et puisqu'on parle de grade on a un
certain nombre on a une procédure
particulière qui permet de zinc et comme
on dit les personnels c'est-à-dire que
lorsque les personnels sont en service
souvent à l'étranger dans le cadre des
opérations extérieures on prend une
décision particulière pour par exemple
si la personne est adjudant chef au
bajaur on le nomme lieutenant à
capitaine c'est un grade visuel mais qui
ne correspond à aucune responsabilité
je dirais de commandement sur le
territoire métropolitain et dans l'est
dans les fonctions opérationnelles
donc on a un certain nombre de
procédures qui là aussi ne nous permette
de nommer des gens
de manière je dirais visuel fictive si
je puis dire et en tout cas pour une
question de positionnement et c'est bien
cet sujet de positionnement qui renvoie
à la question du grade conféré merci mon
général je vais donner par la madame
dernier qui veut compléter sa question
je me posais la question générale il ya
quand même des gens plus fort mais plus
habilité que ce monsieur pour pour
protéger même à l'ambassadeur mon
général
après bon jeu aujourd'hui convient pas
sauf que selon mes informations
à ma connaissance comme on dit il a été
en responsabilité de la sécurité dans un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques
c'est un fait moi j'ai pas à dire est-ce
que c'était bien ou pas bien c'est un
constat il l'a fait dès lors qu'il l'a
fait c'est une expérience qui
m'intéresse mais mon jeu en général dans
le dossier que vous avez eus entre les
mains pour faire ce choix
il n'y avait pas de référence à
l'incident que la presse a rapporté
monsieur benalla aurait été mis à la
disposition d'un membre du gouvernement
en 2012 qui s'en seraient séparés après
un accident automobile et nos tentatives
de délit de fuite
moi monsieur le président je n'ai eu
aucune information de cette sorte
jusqu'à effectivement à ce que ça sorte
dans la presse il ya de trop le mais
jusque là je n'avais aucune information
négative sur deux semaines à la et
encore mois relative à cet incident que
vous évoquez merci mon général je donne
la parole à monsieur kerrouche mon
général de une question très simple
quelle a été votre réaction en tant que
citoyen quand vous vous avez vu les
images du 1er mai quel a été votre
rédaction que votre réaction pardon
quand vous avez su qu'il s'agissait de
réservistes de la gendarmerie nationale
et qu'elle a été aussi votre réaction
quand vous avez su que ces personnes
travaillaient à l'elysée en général
alors merci pour cette question le
sénateur alors moi j'ai vu les images
évidemment la semaine dernière comme
comme tout le monde
avant je n'avais pas je les avais pas
vus j'avais pas vocation à les aléas les
la boire d'ailleurs
c'est vrai que quand on voit les images
elles interpellent
on voit bien que il ya des des actions
qui mérite des explications
maintenant je me garderai bien si vous
le permettez de porter quelques
jugements que ce soit étant pour le coup
par expérience habitués à attendre
condé le film complet avant que de
porter quelques jugements que ce soit
nous avons quand je dis nous les
gendarmes les policiers souvent été mis
en cause nous sommes souvent mis en
cause sur la base d' images qui
lorsqu'on les voit de manière séquencée
et bien entendu suscite peuvent susciter
une réaction mais qui doivent être
replacés dans leur contexte qui doivent
surtout et c'est le cas aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs faire l'objet
d'investigations judiciaires et ça fait
l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire sur
laquelle je me garderai bien de faire
quelque commentaire que ce soit
ge energy a parlé de excusez moi mais
j'ai bien parlé de réactions j'ai bien
je vous ai pas demandé de jugement en
effet je considère qu'en tout cas ça
mérite et c'est le cas que des
investigations sont conduites ces
investigations sont conduites sous
l'autorité de l'inspection générale de
la police nationale sous l'autorité des
magistrats
et voilà il me paraît intéressant
effectivement d'attendre le résultat de
toutes les investigations pour savoir
exactement la manière dont les choses se
sont passées comment elles se sont
passées et qui a fait quoi merci mon
général
madame benbassa mon général ce qui
ressort de vos propos et que vous vous
situez dans une perspective plutôt
théorique
curieusement vous le connaissiez à
monsieur ben alla vous le connaissiez
avant qu'il ne soit à l'elysée mais vous
n'êtes pas du tout au courant de ces
relations à l'elysée avec le j'espère et
vous n'avez pas des vous n'avez pas eu
des remontées
vous dites que vous laissez vos hommes
faire leur travail ce que je comprends
sans vous intéresser davantage
est ce vraiment possible de ne rien
savoir de ce qui se passait au niveau du
j'espère je vous donne ma parole je
précise qu'il nous reste dix minutes à
l'orme à la maçonnerie je comprends
votre question
est ce que c'est possible oui je vous la
firme je n'ai pas compétence pour savoir
ce qui se passe au sein du j'espère ce
n'est pas dans mon domaine de
responsabilités et je vous le dis et je
le répète je me garde et je me garde de
pierre mais moi je considère que le g
espère il a un patron c'est le chef du
gspr qui veut me répond à une autorité
hiérarchique qui est au sein de la
présidence
et je n'ai pas en aucune manière en
aucune sorte à interférer avoir des
renseignements ainsi de suite et c'est
pour moi une question de principe et de
déontologie
je n'ai pas à m'immiscer a mal géré dans
un domaine qui ne ressort pas de vos
domaines de compétences
alors je peux comprendre que ça vous
étonne mais je vous l'affirmé je n'ai
pas à connaître de ce qui se passe au
sein du j'espère et encore moins de ce
qui se passe au palais palais de lille
je crois que mon général donc et c'est
la règle en effet alors madame de la
gontrie
merci monsieur le président mon général
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure
avoir pris connaissance des vidéos
récemment vous avez indiqué avec toutes
les réserves qui vous appartiennent
comment vous les aviez apprécié mais
vous avez indiquée cela interpelle et
j'ai noté cela mérite que des
investigations soient conduites
est-ce que vous pouvez donc confirmé que
selon vous ces faits devaient être
dénoncé au parquet général
merci madame la sénatrice pour cette
question il ya deux deux aspects dans
votre question il ya effectivement le
fait que ça m'interpelle d'autant que
aux mouches découvre la vidéo je sais
qu'il s'agit de monsieur alexandre
benalla puisque c'est ce qui se dit donc
c'est pour ça que je dis ça m'interpelle
parce qu'évidemment je me dis là il faut
qu'on regarde
est ce qu'il était à ce moment là dans
quel statut puisqu'il y avait également
monsieur vincent kraz donc ma question
initiale c'est ça c'est finalement ça
interpelle bon est-ce qu'il était dans
la position de réservistes ou pas voilà
donc ce qui est pris ce qui n'était pas
le cas pour moi très clairement
il ya cette ambiguïté initial qui doit
être levé ensuite est-ce que ça doit
être dénoncée après ça c'est un problème
d'appréciation de la nature de
l'infraction ou pas moi il ne
m'appartient pas de prendre position là
dessus je n'ai pas tous les éléments
d'appréciation
[Musique]
l'autorité qui est celle des différents
responsables doit être là aussi totale
et c'est pas de ma compétence que de
dire il faut dénoncer ce qui est certain
c'est que ça m'interpelle parce que je
sais qu'au moment où je vois la vidéo
ce sont deux personnels qui font l'objet
d'un contrat de réserviste
edmond y des femmes en question initiale
c est ce que ce jour là il était en
fonction de réservistes ou pas parce que
c'est de là découle ma compétence ou non
dès lors qu'ils ne sont pas et je me
suis assuré auprès du camp militaire
bien sûr dès lors qu'ils ne sont pas en
service en tant que réserviste il
échappe à mon domaine de compétence
merci mon général monsieur à la marque
merci monsieur merci président monsieur
frère en général nous avons évoqué
monsieur benalla et et son grade certes
qui est provisoire et c'est un petit peu
un petit peu symbolique première
question y at il quelque une autre
personne et qui a obtenu hockey à
laquelle a été octroyé ce titre à l'âge
de 26 ans ou avant première chose
deuxième chose lorsque 93 ce grade
vous avez dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
commission de ça est ce qu'on a vérifié
ses antécédents de horse ce dont ils se
prévalent et c'est à dire un master de
droit
et puis est-ce qu'on a vérifié son
casier sont quasi judiciaire et ses
intestins
[Musique]
merci pour pour ces questions alors ses
antécédents ont été vérifiés dans le
cadre de sa son recrutement en tant que
réservistes opérationnels en 2009 c'est
à dire que quand on engage un réserviste
il ya un passage au fichier comment dire
on vérifie effectivement qui est pas
d'inscription au casier judiciaire et
qu'ils ne fassent pas l'objet de
poursuites judiciaires diverses et
variées ensuite il a été employé comme
je lisais 194 jours jusqu'en 2015 bon ya
pas eu de remontée négative de 2015 à
2017 il était toujours sous statut et
sert même s'il n'était pas convoqué et
donc on a pas eu
formation qui l'aurait l'est ce qui
aurait laissé à penser qu'il y avait un
problème judiciaire ou qu'il qu'il a eue
qu'il a eu un comportement comportement
anormal
donc là dessus au moment où il change de
statut fin 2017
il n'est pas utile de refaire je dirais
ce travail de criblage comme on dit
parce qu'il a déjà été fait et qu'on est
dans la continuité
il change de statut mais globalement
c'est toujours le même faire globalement
on va pas refaire l'enquète on est aussi
dans une logique de simplification
administrative et et dans le cadre de ce
de ce recrutement il n'est pas apparu il
réglementairement dès lors que on avait
déjà fait le travail
il n'était pas utile de le refaire une
deuxième fois est ce que on a un
réserviste qui est avait le même grade
au même âge à ce stade
à ma connaissance non
maintenant on pourra regarder dans le
détail en termes de réservistes citoyens
si on n'est pas voilà mais j'ai pas fait
le totalité du merci mon général et
maintenant madame trendly merci monsieur
le président général d'abord j'aimerais
vous exprimer très grand respect et la
reconnaissance la gendarmerie nationale
et tout particulièrement les missions
exercées notamment dans nos territoires
ruraux votre écoute et votre
disponibilité en général ma question
rejoint un petit peu celle de monsieur
alain marc et celle que ya été posées
par le président philippe bas vous avez
dit que lorsque vous avez recruté
monsieur benalla ce qui a beaucoup pesé
c'est en fait ces compétences
opérationnelles je me pose la question
d'une enquête de moralité qui aurait
peut-être dû intervenir à nouveau dans
un deuxième temps ma question est la
suivante à aucun moment puisque vous
nous avez parlé des sharks eux qui
étaient chargés de la protection de
nombreuses personnalités qui avaient
pesé dans le recrutement
est ce que à aucun moment il n'a été
porté à votre connaissance
il semblerait qu'il ait eu monsieur
benalla des comportements non
recommandables lorsqu'il était en charge
du protection d'une personnalité
merci chers collègues en général merci
madame la sénatrice pour cette question
merci pour votre soutien
mais non moi je n'ai eu aucune remontée
de d'un comportement inadapté de quelle
que nature que ce soit je le disais
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure sur l'accident
qui a été évoquée à la faveur d'une
mission profit de monsieur montebourg
que j'ai découvert dans la presse je
n'ai eu au moment où on l'a intégré dans
la réserve spécialistes aucune remontée
négative d'aucune sorte sur le
comportement ou l'action monsieur
alexandre bédat la générale madame le
reporter vous poser une question
merci monsieur président oui général à
ce stade de notre audition il ya un
certain nombre d'éléments qui pose
question alors on a bien saisi pour quel
motif vous avez donné ce grade à
monsieur b d'alan qu'ils soient en
réalité à la hauteur de ses
interlocuteurs dans cette mission qui
n'a jamais été mise en oeuvre parce
qu'ils en appellent la disponibilité en
revanche quelques questions qui restent
lorsque vous nous indiquez que vous avez
été motivés donc par cette expérience en
réalité dont il vous a fait pas
par ses compétences et ses diplômes dont
il vous a fait part également puisque en
2009 par définition au regard de sa date
de naissance
il ne pouvait pas les avoir donc c'était
purement déclaratif la question sous
jacente mais en réalité que tout le
monde se pose donc je crois que notre
commission doit la poser aussi c'est un
moment ou un autre
avez vous eu un contact avec l'elysée
sur ce dossier et un moment ou un autre
vous êtes vous vous même influencé par
le fait que cette demande arrivait de
quelqu'un qui se prévalait de ses
fonctions à l'elysée en général merci
pour cette question
la rapporteure là le mérite d'être
tirées et la mairie des directs et 5
donne l'occasion de le dire non à aucun
moment en aucune circonstance personne
ne m'a contacté je n'ai contacté
personnalisés et c'est très clair c'est
une décision personnelle que j'assume
parce que ça fait suite comme je lisais
à des discussions que j'ai eues avec
avec l'intéressé merci beaucoup général
de cette précision monsieur fisher oui
merci monsieur le président mon général
tu simplement ça va je crois qu'il ya un
parallèle un petit peu dans le parcours
de monsieur kraz par rapport au parcours
de monsieur benalla l'un est chef
d'escadron je sais pas quel grade ça
correspond et l'autre devient lieutenant
colonel alors qu'il semblerait que me
suis écrasé une antériorité beaucoup
plus importante que monsieur benalla est
ce qu'il ya une raison au fait que la
haye titre d'expert quel expert l'autre
pas enfin et puis l'autre question c'est
que j'aimerais ça parce que j'ai posé la
question hier j'ai pas une réponse très
précise
est ce que quand on est lieutenant
colonel de réserve on a aussi tous les
attributs c'est-à-dire l'uniforme les
grades et caetera et donc pour accéder
dans les lieux où exercer un
couronnement quelque part en général
merci pour cette question du sénateur
alors les c'est ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer par mon propos liminaire les
deux personnes sont dans un statut
différent le grade du chef d'escadron
donc qui correspond au grade de
commandant vincent kral est un grade
qu'il a obtenu à la faveur du lancement
d'une progression hiérarchique dans le
cas de la réserve opérationnelle de
sécurité publique classique et grade
qu'il concerne globalement il part
demain il revient après demain
il sera toujours chef d'escadron on le
réintègre au même grade et il est
employé dans ses fonctions d'encadrement
il a encadré d'ailleurs des préparations
militaires gendarmerie il a fait plus de
400 jours de réserve depuis 2009 donc
c'est quelqu'un qui est reconnue en plus
comme étant un bon professionnel je
dirais dans le domaine de la rive le
grade de monsieur alexandre viala n'a
rien à boire
ce n'est pas un grade dans le cadre je
dirais d'un réseau opérationnel de
sécurité publique c'est un grade qui
correspond à sa mission qui n'en portent
ni prérogatives de commandement ni
prérogatives de puissance publique port
d'insignes comme vous le soulignez on
est dans une logique de spécialistes il
avait vocation il ne l'a pas fait pour
des raisons pratiques on n'a pas pu le
convoquer mais il n'a pas vocation à
commander les gens au même titre
d'ailleurs que la réserve citoyenne n'a
pas vocation pour ce qui nous concerne a
porté la tenue ce qui n'est pas le cas
par exemple pour nos amis de la marine
les réservistes citoyens peuvent porter
l'uniforme et en ce qui concerne l'armée
nationale l'uniforme il est porté par
des réservistes opérationnels qui ont
des missions de sécurité publique
générale au quotidien et donc les les
statuts vraiment de monsieur vincent
kraz monsieur alexandre da sont
totalement différents
monsieur leroy oui monsieur le président
merci mon général vous parlez
effectivement beaucoup de spécialités et
c'est vrai que les gendarmes sont
spécialisés dans la sécurité et
notamment dans la protection des
autorités puisque quand on sait la
formation la durée de la formation les
qualités et les capacités du j espère qu
homme du gign dans le cadre votre avis
m'intéresse pensez vous que l'apport de
personnes non alignés sur la même
fréquence que les pros de la sécurité
rapprochée pourrait constituer un danger
ou un handicap pour l'autorité protéger
en général
je suis pas sûr d'avoir bien compris la
question
e moi je considère que les gens
notamment s'agissant du président mais
aussi l'ensemble des autorités
ministérielles protégé par les
personnels du j'espère pour le président
du sdlp pour les autorités de premier
niveau
ces protections sont faites par des
gendarmes ou des policiers
s'agissant des autorités et à ma
connaissance il n'ya pas d'immixtion
quelque nature que ce soit enfin j'ai
pas connaissance de ça en même temps
c'est pas mon domaine de compétence donc
je suis mal placé pour vous réponds mais
très clairement
moi je constate que les gendarmes du
gspr en tout cas ne manquons pas faire
remonter difficultés et que globalement
ils font leur métier au quotidien avec
leurs camarades la police nationale
alors monsieur oeuvre rapidement
oui très rapidement autrement dit
effectivement la protection rapprochée
de benalla du président ne pouvait-il
pas gêner effectivement l'action du
j'espère qu'ils sont des pros de la
garde rapprochée
l'appréciation technique je suis bien
incapable pardon de répondre à cette
question d'abord parce que je suis pas
moi-même spécialistes en matière de
protection des personnes je n'ai jamais
tenu aucune fonction ni aucune formation
d'un logo de la protection des personnes
donc là moi je sais pas comment sont
organisées le dispositif au sein de
délier c'est pas dans mon domaine de
compétence et je suis à ce stade
incompétent pour répondre à la question
merci mon général
nous avons maintenant la question madame
canayer merci président général que
effectivement personne ne connaissait
les antécédents de monsieur benalla que
les choses semblent particulièrement le
cloisonné alors que sur le terrain on a
l'impression qu'il ya plutôt de
confusion entre les différents acteurs
dans cette affaire là néanmoins je
voudrais poser une question un peu plus
précise sur le port d'armes dont était
bénéficiaire monsieur benalla plus tard
vous en tant que forces de l'ordre
autorités qui régule l'ordre public
il était normal et réglementaire que
monsieur benalla soit titulaire d'un
port d'armes
eu égard aux fonctions qu'il semblait
exercer dans le maintien de l'ordre en
général
merci madame la sénatrice pour cette
question le port d'armes pour ce qui
nous concerne
s'agissant de personnel de la réserve il
les autorise et que dans le cadre des
missions de sécurité publique
en l'espèce lorsque monsieur vincent
kraz étaient convoqués comme réserviste
à ce moment là quand il prenait son
service il percevait son armement sous
l'autorité et le contrôle d'un personnel
d'actifs et lorsqu'il terminait son
service il remettait son arme au
râtelier sous l'autorité et le contrôle
d'un personnel c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne et que tous les réservistes
finalement perçoivent et réintègre
l'armement
monsieur b dallas n'avait pas vocation
dans sa fonction spécialistes à être
titulaire en apportant au titre de
seconde sur qualité de réserviste
sur le reste en termes d'emploi
le les autorisation de port d'armes ne
sont pas de mon domaine de compétence je
n'ai pas autorité pour délivrer ou même
donner un avis sur le port d'armes de
qui que ce soit
ce n'est pas de la responsabilité de
jean-louis nationale et la
responsabilité dont était préfectoral et
les autorités hiérarchiques
moi j'ai pas de responsabilité la seule
responsabilité que j'ai pour aller au
bout de la réponse c'est pour mes
militaire d'activ de les autoriser à
avoir des tenir là en dehors du service
saas et suite aux différents attentats
qui ont endeuillé notre notre pays suite
aux agressions notamment je pense à
magnanville de nos camarades de la
police nationale
il a été mis en place un dispositif qui
permet aux gendarmes d'activ en dehors
du service de détenir leurs armes après
autorisation je dirais donnée par le
commandant donc c'est le seul domaine
dans lequel j'ai une compétence
quelconque pour entre guillemets en
détention ou un port d'armes hors
service merci mon général
le président caennais oui monsieur le
président mon général tout à l'heure
vous avez déclaré devant la commission
sous serment que rien ne vous avait
influencé dans le langage de monsieur
benalla à 26 ans pour devenir lieutenant
colonel de réserve au regard des faits
qui lui sont potentiellement maintenant
reprochés est ce qu'il ya un risque que
le dézingage pour être clair de
rétrogradation de son grade
au regard de la responsabilité qui a été
la sienne dans les éléments que nous
avons nous ont pris connaissance i merci
pour en revenir à la merci monsieur
l'auteur pour cette question alors il y
a dix ya deux choses qui qui dont l'une
est déjà en vigueur et l'autre est
potentiellement en cours donc la
première c'est qu'évidemment à la fois
monsieur benalla et monsieur kraz ne
sont pas cons ne sont plus convoqué
comme on les aime très clairement on
suspend les convocations comme ça
globalement en attendant plus ample
informé c'est ce qu'ont fait
traditionnellement pour tous les
réservistes qui peuvent parce que ça
peut arriver aussi
avoir un problème de déontologie ou
d'actions en situant les suspentes
convocation c'est à dire qu'on ne les
emploie plus et ensuite
traditionnellement on laisse courir le
le contrat et on ne renouvelle pas
pourquoi parce que si on souhaite radier
la personne la procès de radiation elle
est encadrée par un texte que je peux
mettre à votre disposition qui nécessite
la réunion d'une commission s'agissant
de deux officiers doit réunir deux
officiers d'activé quatre officiers de
réserve et doit faire l'objet
je dirais d'une procédure qui est
équivalente à celle d'un conseil dans
quête pour un militaire d'actifs et
alors c'est pas tant la procédure et
même qui pose problème c'est le fait
qu'il faille convoqué l'intéressé pour
l'entendre sur les faits vous comprenez
bien que à ce stade est en double qui
est une enquête judiciaire en cours
je ne peux pas convoqué l'intéressé pour
l'entendre sur les faits sauf à
interférer ou possiblement m'immiscer
dans cette enquête judiciaire donc à ce
stade ils sont tous les deux suspendus
de convocation et au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée des investigations judiciaires
et des éléments qui seront portées à ma
connaissance et en seule autorité du
ministre bien entendu nous prendrons les
mesures
lorsqu'on pourra les prendre sans
interférer bien entendu sur les enquêtes
sur l'enquêté judiciaire
merci mais ça l'est de notre rapporteur
madame jourdain une ultime question à
vous poser
merci monsieur président général avez
vous été informé d'un projet de fusion
du j'espère et du commandement militaire
et le cas échéant vais vous été
consultés sur ce point merci madame leur
apporter eau pour cette question alors
je n'ai pas été consulté très clairement
j'ai été informé en revanche j'ai été
informé parce que bien entendu ça a des
conséquences en matière comme je lisais
de mise à disposition des personnels et
de l'ajustement budgétaire
mais je n'ai pas été consulté d'ailleurs
je n'avais pas là ce n'est pas dans mon
domaine de compétence ont peut-être que
si quand même
monsieur le directeur général mais enfin
c'est une appréciation sur lequel il
n'ya pas d'inconvénient à être en
désaccord
voilà et je vous remercie d'avoir été
coopératif dans le cadre de cette
audition est de nous avoir éclairé